Eine Stadt bevölkert von Sagenfiguren
– im historischen Zentrum von Hameln
tummeln sich Helden aus
Märchen und Legenden.
Und jede Menge Ratten.
Sie erinnern an eine der berühmtesten
Sagenfiguren Deutschlands:
den Rattenfänger von Hameln.
Der soll hier vor mehr als 700 Jahren
sein Unwesen getrieben haben
und ist bis heute vielen ein Begriff.
Es ist halt eine schöne Geschichte, ne,
also die von Generation zu Generation
immer weitergegeben wird.
'Ne schöne Mütze mit so einer Feder,
das ist für mich der Rattenfänger.
Bisschen bunt gekleidet, so wie er
hier manchmal in Hameln rumläuft.
Ich kenne den Rattenfänger
aus Märchenbüchern,
die mir schon meine Eltern
vorgelesen haben.
Berühmt wurde der Rattenfänger
dank der Sagensammlung
der Brüder Jakob und Wilhelm Grimm.
Vor 200 Jahren veröffentlichten sie
einen Band mit zahlreichen Erzählungen
wie jener über einen Spielmann, der
Hameln von einer Rattenplage befreite.
Als er kein Geld bekam,
entführte er kurzerhand
die Kinder mit seiner Flötenmusik.
Zwar gab es schon frühere Überlieferungen,
aber die berühmten
Märchensammler Grimm
machten den Rattenfänger
international bekannt.
Die Sage wurde in mehr als
30 Sprachen übersetzt.
Dadurch, dass die Brüder Grimm auch
mit ihren anderen Werken so populär sind,
hat davon der Rattenfänger
unglaublich profitiert.
Sehr, sehr populär is[t] er im ganzen
angloamerikanischen Bereich,
in Europa ohnehin. Auch in Asien ist
eine ganz große Rattenfänger-
und überhaupt Märchen-
und Sagen-Begeisterung.
Und davon profitiert Hameln.
Jedes Jahr kommen laut Angaben der Stadt
3,8 Millionen Menschen her, um sich auf
die Spuren des Rattenfängers zu begeben.
Oder ihn live zu erleben.
Michael Boyer ist seit 22 Jahren
offizieller Rattenfänger von Hameln.
Der US-Amerikaner kennt die Geschichte
noch aus Kindertagen.
Ich hab' schon in der dritte[n] Schulklasse
vom Rattenfänger gelesen.
Und schon damals die Geschichte
nicht geglaubt, dass
so ein Pfeifer, der Ratten aus der Stadt
entführen kann und Kinder auch,
dann nicht sein Geld bekommt
vom Bürgermeister
mit ein[er] magischen Geschichte.
Mit magische[r] Musik.
Und so dachte ich, als ich erfuhr,
dass es Hameln hier tatsächlich gibt:
Das ist schön, ich lerne das.
Viele der faszinierenden Geschichten
der Brüder Grimm
wurden in Kassel aufgeschrieben,
wo die Brüder lange lebten.
Im interaktiven Museum „Grimm Welt“
kann man ihren bekanntesten
Figuren begegnen:
dem Froschkönig
oder den sieben Zwergen
von Schneewittchen.
Doch Jakob und Wilhelm Grimm waren
mehr als nur Märchensammler.
Die studierten Juristen waren auch Politiker,
und sie begannen, das deutsche
Wörterbuch zu erstellen.
Ein Mammutprojekt, das erst nach
ihrem Tod fertig wurde.
Sie haben dieses alte Kulturgut,
die Märchen und die Sagen, gesammelt,
haben das in eine gemeinsame
Form gebracht
und haben damit ein Werk geschaffen,
was dann auch zu der großen Verbreitung
weltweit beigetragen hat.
Die Geschichten haben viele Künstler
inspiriert und wurden oft im Kino gezeigt.
Ob früher als Scherenschnitt
oder als Animationsfilm,
wie hier „Der gestiefelte Kater“.
Bis heute greift vor allem Hollywood auf
die Märchen der Brüder Grimm zurück,
wie kürzlich mit dem
Oscar-nominierten Cinderella,
einer modernen Aschenputtel-Version.
Auch die Rattenfänger-Sage wurde oft
auf die Leinwand gebracht.
Bekannt ist der Disney-Zeichentrickfilm
von 1933.
Doch was unterscheidet eigentlich
die Sage von einem Märchen?
Sagen haben immer mindestens
einen historischen Bezug,
wie man zum Beispiel hier an der
Rattenfänger-Sage
in Hameln gut feststellen kann.
Das hat hier wirklich gespielt,
so oder so ähnlich.
Doch ob nun Sage oder Märchen,
vor allem bei Kindern kommen die
Geschichten der Brüder Grimm an.
Auch nach mehr als 200 Jahren.